[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
welcome back to the breakup room our
daily show that keeps you updated on all
their
you know that we are going to be talking
about house of dragons i like to call it
cottage of lizards uh well he's gonna
talk about how we feel about mortal
kombat two mortal kombat two be
announced test your might
that's
moral
that's going to be a mandatory fun one
of these days yes we're all going to
dance to the mortal kombat three years
when mortal kombat 2 comes out
we will be dancing oh fun fact when i
used to go to raves that song would play
every time oh yeah along with captain
planet san diego comic con begins
tomorrow and yeah i wish i was there and
you thought that was big we have a huge
announcement about what's happening at
new rock stars that we're going to give
you in some math
fun
uh get those celebrating emojis ready
today i have john costa here hi i have
two hands oh yeah seven toes but uh
that's also true yeah they fall over
very easily wow i thought it was just
because you clumsy
what's up big head gang bills mafia gang
all my gangs coming together into a
personhood
a unity
a cult led by me your leader camera four
thank you very much
we are so close
so close to tomicon becoming a real
thing we're nearly a few hundred dollars
away and like i said the bigger we go
over a thousand the bigger tamakon will
be and i've got a little announcement
for you right now after we introduce our
other hosts oh i got angelica trey got
some suspects i don't think i was gonna
come out on the show yeah oh okay all
right i'm excited for that um hi hello
uh it's good to be back i can slow blink
look at me go whoa
oh like a computer new character from
early cgi animation it makes me scary
uncomfortable our redemptions today for
every 100 dollars we get in super chats
we'll be giving you a spicy ad not not
that kind of spicy unless you give a
little bit more we'll be eating one of
these horrible disaster ridden chips and
selling you on a very hot product you
get it you get it yeah yeah yeah
these are ghost pepper chips just to be
clear that is the flavor of this chip is
ghost pepper we bought a hundred of
those little one chip challenge things
and then dumped them all into it it's
like so it's gonna suck youtube if you i
i'm not saying i want us to get to
comic-con today but if we don't i'll be
okay yeah
i don't need to eat the spicy thing and
to reiterate what tommy did say if we
get to comic con we have to reach a
thousand by end today friday and you can
expect on uh monday 7 25 july 25th to be
a virtual convention baby yes it is like
7 25 we've raised
725 dollars
so just a couple quick announcements on
comic con as i i will be out the next
couple of days so uh
yeah i have to get ready for it for the
for the convention we've already
announced the brandon barrick
four-minute soapbox panel the
three-minute jessica clemens tribute
zach huddleston will have
five minutes to sing a virtual concert
based on his win yesterday uh but i want
to announce now that comic-con is
presenting a mini convention inside
starting monday comic-con will present
jess fest that's right jessica clemons
will be holding a mini convention inside
tomicon
uh
not the first time jess has been inside
tom uh convention wise so convention
wise so uh conventionally so well we're
very excited to present just fest so
guys let's get that money going
comic-con just fest
we got huddleston singing we got barrack
talking about whatever he wants again a
three-minute tribute to jessica clemons
and a whole fest of her own maybe we'll
cancel one of those things can we
confirm it's gonna be it's gonna be the
two of you plus zach and brandon on
monday's show for that we better do that
i also want to say i want to announce
our first and probably last exclusive
i have found a stack of my first
headshots and if you pledge
if you pledge a certain we'll come up
with an amount of money i will send you
a signed ridiculous it's a it's a much
skinnier much younger tommy bechtold
with in prayer hands with a blues
brothers shirt it'll be worth it guys
okay my god so that's our exclusive a
signed uh embarrassing head shot of me
and we will find a way to send it to you
what should i send yeah well we got to
work on that guys a lot of by the way we
haven't raised enough money yet so who
even knows if it's going to happen
that's right perfect also someone in the
chat asks will there be a kissing booth
and of course there is there's always
gonna be a kissing booth at comic-con uh
we also have our tick-tock yes we are on
tick-tock now follow us the break room
is on the talk as i call it at the
underscore breaker angelico you're no
stranger to tick-tock you're a tic-tock
phenomenon oh oh thank you um yeah the
tick-tock is great yeah i'm excited to
see more of break room goodies yes yes
follow us for even more break room
content we're so excited about that yes
we're close to a thousand followers
which sounds small but uh it's exciting
to us so if you haven't fought us on
tick tock already um
do it what the f
we can yeah
can we swear you can say frick probably
yeah okay
we're gonna get to the headlines in a
second we're gonna get to comic con news
in a second we got some housekeeping to
do
if you are on our discord if you're not
get in there if you are um we wanna hear
your lovely voice um we love everyone in
the chat we also love hearing things so
uh there's a channel in there where you
can drop in your voicemails ask us a
question it'll be more likely to be
answered on the show because we're
trying things out um get in there we
want to hear uh your craziest comic-con
predictions we'll be running through
those up until saturday when we do our
live comic-con show this saturday me
no not me jessica clements erica
zack huddleston are going to be live
during the marvel hall h panel at 5 00
p.m on saturday talking about all the
crazy stuff i will be performing a
wedding ceremony but if they facetime me
i'll answer we do have a fake ad read to
do so much to my chagrin oh are we going
to do it or do they do the poll i think
we just said we volunteered because we
don't want to torture anyone i want to
try it so i guess i'll do the next one
jessica will do the next one uh or you
can do this one if you want you go first
i want to see how you react well uh we
want to thank our
oh god oh god baby do you have water do
you you don't have water wait do they
know what that is only flans
only plans
is a sexy dessert company
no the rivers
plant
oh my god no why'd you do a second i
mean whether you're supposed to be
inviting me oh no
oh baby oh no
oh no oh hold on oh lordy lord tommy
tommy call me nutty the ghost of tommy
we'll bring you
a gourmet authentic mexican dessert
experience
straight to your door completely naked
each month you pledge to only
another
we will bring you a different style of
flan
that will blow your mind
and blow your butt
that's what you got in your box uh it's
time to get into the headlines you got
it you gotta you gotta cool off for a
second oh my gosh skipping all this
other crap we were supposed to do thank
you for playing the graphics you guys a
new house of dragon trailer came out
today
angelica will you do me a solid really
quick i'm so sorry interrupt we hear
that bag right there the bag behind the
uh the hammer the bag behind the hammer
yeah the chip bag please
yeah that that no they're holding it the
people in the chat that say these are
just normal doritos oh these are the
pacquiao chips oh yeah yeah these are
very real they're real two people oh my
god leo lopez with the 50 donation one
of us is so screwed uh new house of the
dragon trailer dropped today there's
blonde people there are dragons there
are other an iron throne um we're
getting super excited for house of the
dragon here i'm sure a lot of people are
out there um first impressions thoughts
tommy you go first okay first of all
no stop what is he doing keep going i am
the dragon
you are a nightmare i am the dragon
i can confirm new rockstars will have a
presence at the premiere
of this game of thrones show
so we will give you the scoops i love
game of thrones i love the targaryens
what family doesn't have a couple
cousins that like to kiss each other
brothers and sisters that weirds me out
i think this show looks good i think
tonally it reminds me of like season two
and three of game of thrones
aka the pretty horse in the drawing the
game of thrones drawing before it all
falls off
i love the actors i think you have to
just
we all need to go reset in our brains
and enjoy game of thrones again for what
it is which is a really fun fantasy
property and you know kind of forget
about what happened to us in the last
season oh my god fake ad redeemed again
trauma's all about marrying you yeah i
got you while you read the ad i'm gonna
go get it i think tommy now is ibs so
yeah oh no that's how that will be on
diabetes i'll do just one chip we'll see
how it goes beyond bs
oh my god
these are going to oh
oh no i got you fast yeah that one
it was the air it was the air
why didn't we do that
do not we got a new special for you guys
coming to you from compton california
it's called hood wheel water does
nothing no you thought you meant
goodwill no hood wheel is where you can
buy every kind of
a hubcap from any
brand new
water just spreads the seeds right now i
need milk this is not good
you can get clothes from 50
you can get clothes made by 25 cents
you can get oh
it's in my nose you can get
you can get anything you want from hood
wheels you want a rock boiler we got
five of them you want a
a cane corso we got two of them they're
really hard to feed go ahead to go to
goodwill and ask for jessica but don't
say my last name because i owe a lot of
money to the government oh my god this
is horrible it's spreading like a
symbiote suit throughout my insides
tommy today we were just going to do
fake ad reads um
and we wanted to spice it up quite
literally and this was this is tommy's
idea uh i just i don't regret it i want
you to know i feel like i'm getting a
workout um
game of thrones great mortal kombat 2
next headline has been announced i did
not see the first movie um bad nerd um
but it would be directed by the same
director simon mcquoid um
any breakers out there uh what are you
more excited about are you more excited
about uh
uh mortal kombat 2 you're more excited
about house the dragon let me know oh my
god wait i think i think i think a big i
think thomas film juice you nightmare
you absolute nightmare so
this episode of the break room is
brought to you by tomicon
yo
i'm not going with spicy food
but
in honor of the spicy challenge that
we're doing today comic-con will be in
an inferno we will be bringing fire
machines to comic-con tomicon will come
to your house and light it on fire
um
any other fire-based activities that
we're going to be doing flamethrowers
we're going to have flamethrowers tommy
and jessica fire eaters we're going to
fire you anthony ramos is going to
confirm once again that iron heart [ __ ]
is fire
someone asked me if we knew that that
meant it was going to be good yes we are
aware that that meant it was coming he
was like it's a [ __ ] fire you guys are
going to just play fire starter over and
over again on repeat the loop we love
that film we were going to read it we're
going to stay here and read the song
if you would like to save ten percent
these are not that spicy if you'd like
to save time you're so full of [ __ ]
every election i know
ten percent i i your for your comic-con
passes please go to breakroom.com
comic-con yes and have you heard of it
god
uh you know you're still doing these i
feel awesome headline dc's blue beetle
movie just wrapped maybe they'll
announce that [ __ ] at comic con is that
what
someone tell me anything about blue
beetle there's a cool costume okay
really cool jason sedegas not gonna be
in it okay gonna be in it i don't know
any more details he's a young latino
super hero
he's really
he's really fun and really magnificent
and he's a great character great uh and
especially an injustice too did i eat
the wrong chips
i don't know this episode's already and
tommy will keep doing it because this
episode's already on you don't think
they're spicy no they are very spicy oh
my god whoo
this is what we call in wrestling and no
cell oh i said it's the aftertaste and
it's on the side of my it's on the side
of my head to breathe hard to breathe um
we're gonna get to comic con in a second
some new concept art
from rise of skywalker remember that
movie shows leia with the purple
lightsaber this is really cool because
back in the day
uh carrie fisher was just like oh what
kind of lightsaber would you want if you
had a lightsaber and she said she would
love a purple one so they were thinking
about honoring her with that i think we
have an image of it oh my god
oh what is it it's not spicy
it's pretty spicy
it's coming at me like it's coming at me
lately
uh this was sort of during that
flashback where luke and leia were
training um i think it would have been
great well what is can i i was thinking
about this when i was like reading this
so the concept art was it is a concept
already technically just created like
fan wise no this would have been like
during pre-production when they were
like what do we want this movie to look
like oh
okay and that is what they would hire
artists to be like it's a way to
visualize
it
barbie has finished shooting
barbie watch is on hiatus oh god um
the barbie movie has finished shooting
ryan gosling gave a great interview who
said ken is going to be down on his luck
in the new barbie movie he said ken's
got no job he's got no car he's got no
house he's going through my god so ken
is me
okay
these chips are not there they're coming
at me late yeah that's what i said it's
a slow burn it's making my tummy hurt
these chips are like a relationship that
starts off really fun and then you
realize it's only fun because you're
both crazy and doing a lot of drugs oh
so we're toxic yeah
the taste of your lips
get them some milk yeah yeah where's our
milk man daschle
next headline ryan gosling speaking of
ken um
uh gave that interview earlier this week
and said he wanted to play ghost writer
yeah he's back at it again
when asked if he uh had ever
everyone in the chat thank you so much
why did you give so much money so early
you know what it was i was nice to them
i didn't call them garbage i
and all of a sudden the money came
flowing in this was all g-fuel
going to make things worse you're um
charged right now jesus christ when the
shows get off the rails it's like i i
feel bad for people who are watching
after the fact the chat i'm sure you
guys have a great time ryan gosling back
at it again
uh when
he was being interviewed by uh uh
happy sad confused is that the podcast
um and he was sort of like he was asked
you know how many times have you had to
turn down superhero
and he sort of skirted around the
question he was like um you know
they weren't the right roles
he did say
he wanted to play captain canada ah
for all you
superhero fans out there i know there's
a couple of you in the chat um
it is a real character yeah uh a real
character introduced in the 1970s
basically captain america of canada
um from montreal uh and um
it's not gonna happen i guess is what
i'm trying to do i also was like because
if marvel had to do that it would have
to also be published in america and i
don't know how many americans would be
like oh you know what we were talking
was that alpha flight is a canadian
superhero team brandon has been pushing
on this show the last few days
that could be fun to have them be part
of uh part of a marvel thing if you do a
team that's well i think that's where
you get them yes if you do a team but
one person and and then the whole thing
is just being candidates yeah yeah
because at least alpha flight they're
they're they have powers that are cool
now and also i do want to point out
thank you to whoever i think it was uh
someone named lillian said this is a
hashtag thirsty thespian moment and
speaking of thirsty thespians
my god i could go for a milkshake right
now it's not bringing that up
uh speaking of concept art miss marvel
just ended we loved it there was some
new concept art that teased a little bit
of a different power set for miss marvel
not in beginning yes like we may be some
head oh my god somebody's a little
somebody's donated a hundred dollars
yeah no way i thought it was two wait no
it's 200 uh oh another fake ad maybe
somebody's sitting
everyone should eat some chips let's
cheers on it okay
the break room is brought to you by
samuel josiah
who
just said more chaos
a canadian himself probably just jealous
that uh captain canada will never be a
part of the marvel cinematic universe
screw that samuel this one's for you
camera four let me talk about my
relationship with canada a little bit oh
niagara falls growing up is one of my
favorite places criminal hall of fame
wax museum you gotta see it
casino niagara some of the hottest slots
in town loose slots hot shots
7-eleven is how crafts is played now let
me talk about toronto
color in toronto
right on spadina
you take the film you drop it off we're
talking about orillia canada and
paramount scandalous wonderland where
they play the top gun theme where they
play the star trek theme where they play
the superman theme canada's wonderland
is the premier theme park in north
america if you don't think canada is
america's loving helmet protecting us
from our stupidity you're out of your
mind more canadian superheroes now
more canadian superheroes
twenty dollars forever from another one
this is brought to you by uh
bouncy the quicker picker hopper i'm
gonna lay down for a minute actual ads
at this point um
the quicker um
that smiles back
this um this episode of the break room
is brought to you by our next headline
there was some miss marvel concept art
that teased some different powers
inspired from video games can we show
the image
did we already do it very interesting
kind of looks like a platform
oh my god why don't we do this to
ourselves
sort of looks like a platformer game i
love the direction that they went with
their powers i don't think this would
have worked but a cool interesting
concept sort of like
you know
a little green lanterny a little uh
fortnite builder um
um
i prefer what we got i'll say that oh
god i'm just zipping through these
headlines because i'm dying tom holland
is not gonna play peter parker in
spider-man freshman year that's an
animated show don't worry um are you
guys ready he didn't play peter parker
and what if
he's not going to play peter parker in
freshman year this is via illuminati so
take that for what it's worth
jesus christ mls beer beads
oh my god this we got a cap are we going
to cap this redemption no
no
okay that's it for headlines
oh my god we're going to talk about san
diego comic-con in a second i promised
you that no i like when the comments are
like they never talked about it
are you ready
yeah we're gonna just like hot ones
we're gonna start getting very defensive
very mean just because we're being
tortured just because we're being
milford here we go i only can drink oat
milk i'm lactose intolerant here we go
oh no get one i have to do another i
just um jessica and i will take this one
no i'll do a little baby one you weren't
an iron man
angelica i just walked in they're like
here's the thing is the first bite is
good but then it hits my the dangly
angley thing in the hanging of the back
of my throat watch that damn thing right
in the back of my throat is this ghost
pepper what is this yeah it's a reaper
pepper
reaper okay you guys
yep
what's up
san diego
oh no ad read san diego
what we're going to read it's after it's
after oh oh the chip the ship um this
brought to you by
um
the book stars we don't have coffee but
we spit in your mouth i can't talk to
you great i want to thank our sponsors
today at
gru rockstars the only minions based
youtube breakdown channel that covers
all minions all the time despicable
mourn despicable me 2. despicable me 3
minions minions 2 rise of groove and all
of the rides and theme park attractions
can be caught on our sister channel the
101 minion
grew rock stars the giant minion that is
my christ that watches over me as i
travel down the 101 to meet my drug
dealer at the kettle donuts
uh
really giving away too many of our
locations
next headline you ready yeah yeah san
diego comic-con begins tomorrow and
don't worry we're not gonna be there
either director james gunn is getting
people ramped up about the marvel h harl
h
marvel hall h presentations on twitter
already all the news is exciting and sad
because i can't be there but it's okay
because we'll be here on saturday to
talk it
talk it down with you guys no you're
good i can't even read right now all
right we're getting uh so these are the
shows that we that we know what we're
getting we're getting from marvel we're
getting black panther too
we're getting she-hulk uh for the
animated panel we're getting x-men 97
some marvel zombies what if season two
and more for dc
yep sorry
dc we have black adam shazam fury of the
gods harley quinn season three advanced
screening and for rick and for uh
we have rick and morty at the house of
the dragon ah here's what we could be
getting we could be getting uh henry
cavill returning a superman announcement
aquaman two uh fl the flash updates blue
beetle uh for disney we could be getting
werewolf by night guardians the galaxy
three the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special blade quantum mania loki
season 2 uh the secret invasion
there are so many things that could be
coming
and now we're asking yes
all drinks
oh yeah keep going keep going
keep going no i need you to finish
we need to sit as a unit at this part so
there's so many things that could be
potentially happening a lot of things
that are happening
um as a unit we kind of believe and i
kind of want to get again no i don't
think we think this is going to happen
we know what's going to happen mm-hmm
no
speculative who's in charge of this part
of the part what's going on guys push
through come on we think as a unit that
we might get some fantastic four updates
oh does that seem that seem fair yes
uh there's been news online uh that i
don't think we've talked about on here
much but disney releasing the mutants
uh live action the mutants hopefully uh
young avengers will probably be
announced in avengers 5.
do we think we're gonna actually oh guys
nevermind let john do it let's uh just
because we're all hot chipping ahead
right now we're all hot in the head
right now yeah um
there was this interesting article from
deadline today that was talking about
what marvel was planning to announce at
san diego comic con yes and they
listened at the bottom like a bunch of
stuff that
you know was maybe not going to happen
at comic-con yeah it's so bad um
everyone is in such bad shape right now
we should have been we should have
banked this for the end yeah instead
we're halfway through this episode it's
fine there was a but this article
was is it listed it they said um not to
expect a ton from comic-con although we
have sources inside of new rockstars
that beg to differ which is really
interesting
um
but at the bottom of that article they
said something like
you know things not to expect at
comic-con
they listed things like blade the
marvels things titles that we knew had
been announced
including a new title called the mutants
yes right yeah that's what i said yeah
that is just like i'm really i'm sorry i
might have been getting drinks yeah i
think that's just like a really
interesting
is it a
slip up yeah deadline uh is it an
unofficial announcement by deadline well
i think it's a safe
calling it the mutants is a really safe
title for the property because it can
turn into whatever right it could be
x-men it could be a compilation of new
mutants not that any mutants but new
mutants in the mcu
it really
lets them off the hook of having to
declare what something is specifically
we're going backwards it's just vague
enough yes exactly
i'm just pulling up our beautiful list
so we can you know see what we want to
do do you think we can get some doctor
doom
i think we'll see doc i'm writing him in
2022.
okay that's all i'll say
off-screen pronunciation i love that
anyone tuning in late to the break room
just thinks the cast is falling and
falling apart yeah we are we're all
in tears i felt my soul leave my body
yes
brandon uh if you're out there call in
how happy are you you're not on the show
um okay we've got some interesting super
chats about uh comic con s elizabeth
says biggest announcement do you think
we'll be at san diego comic con or d23
do you think we'll have a heavier d23
show or a heavier comic-con show
yeah that's true my thought is
this is just my speculation
the
the state the status of star wars and
and marvel right now is a state of kind
of confusion amongst the fans i think
this is marvel's attempt at comic-con to
kind of like stabilize the ship and be
like don't worry guys here's all this
amazing stuff that's going to come out
and then at d23 they can simply add to
that but i feel like the decision kind
of last minute to have the panel
at comic-con was them being like we
gotta act now before everybody just
starts going like i can't track all this
stuff i'm not interested anymore because
really if they lose the kids then
they lose everything you think this is
like a phase four is gonna be okay yeah
i think this is like some triage a
little light tree i don't think they
need it i'm enjoying what all the
content they're putting out i promise
kevin
oh oh is that the challenge
did you touch your eye after you touched
the chip ah no but uh i think that uh
yeah i think they just need to reassure
everyone you okay no
it is interesting the panel is only an
hour long it's from 5 p.m to 6 p.m um
which you know is relatively short yeah
yeah we know we're getting black panther
too we know we're getting shield yeah um
but all the things that just listed off
you know are not guaranteed outside of
some of those animated projects right um
i'm curious to hear from you guys like
what do you think in addition to those
two things what is the most likely
project we'll hear about oh i think
fantastic four right is that what you
just said i don't know i i think like i
don't even think that that movie has
been cast yet wakanda wakanda forever
that's happening for sure yeah yeah but
oh you mean like
it's but like just like this is no i
mean so we we know we're getting wakanda
forever we know we're getting shielded i
thought we're gonna get an update like
just actually i think we're probably
we're finally in like the trailer yeah
but i think i think what john's asking
is what do you think that isn't uh
confirmed to be there okay
so that's why i said like we uh
give me one second
okay scroll faster oh you want to come
yeah yeah i've got to go that's why we
have the fantastic four the mutants
young avengers or avengers five like
those aren't actually going to be there
right what they could they would like
blow the lid off of the con if they were
like hey avengers 5 is happening in
secret i think we're getting a i think
we're going to get uh young avengers or
dark avengers because they have been
they've been that that's been the most
heavily teased right at least with
character introductions
that that that could be a pathway
heading i mean we have what's val up to
i think dark avengers is a fun one yeah
and that would be a great idea give us
the dark avengers i gotta say guys
this isn't an ad reed
it could it could be this is working the
best at cutting the spice that's the
grapefruit one only the bubbles can cut
the spice oh my god
okay
uh i hope it's the mutants uh because
we're talking so much about it and we're
clear and it would go with my theory
that we're not gonna get x-men but we
will get mutants i love that theory i
also think it's interesting kevin feige
excuse you
you got something to say i'm just
laughing at how ridiculous this show is
the kevin feige at the 2019 panel
obviously like blade was sort of like
the one more thing announcement with
ursula coming out and putting the hat on
but he did sort of say like as he was
saying goodbye to everyone he was like
also mutants so
i would i wouldn't that's why when
people were like there's man i was like
no he said mutants
yeah he specified he said mutants he
said mutants so okay i want to i want to
go to these things that we sort of said
maybe we're going to happen do we think
we'll
do you think they'll finally announce
werewolf by night it's coming in october
no they've had nothing i think they
should announce that uh november 1st
oh last month we dropped it on the
simpsons page
also whoever whoever hacked into my
disney plus and keeps changing the
language to french i'm not i'm not
changing it back you're welcome to use
my disney plus i'm glad you figured out
my login if you're watching now you have
succeeded and i will not stop you i like
watching songs listen you win a lot of
people in the chat are saying the
thunderbolts roster being announced yeah
because we don't have too many right i
only have oh no i'm thinking
oh i was like we have iron heart and i
was like oh wait not same thing not the
same thing
yeah that's interesting too like these
d23 shows we've got disney plus day or
d23 shows disney plush shows we've got
disney plus day coming in september
so we'll probably get a lot of
announcements there but do we think
we'll hear anything about armor wars
secret invasion
iron hearts i feel like they'll do a
teaser maybe for like secret invasion or
something at least
and and you know just previously going
off of like thunderbolts too maybe a
little like sneak peek of that because
we know ironheart has shot uh shits fire
uh we know
a secret innovation has shot loki season
two is shooting right now i think like
agatha house of harkness is maybe in
production as well
there's a lot of these disney plush
shows that we could i hope we get a
teaser for householders house of
harkness might be my most
i am very excited i mean yeah loki
season two is is no i i i am also
because i just don't know what house of
harkness is going to be about other than
katherine han being agatha and that's
all i need i just want music i want some
i hope there's some good songs oh yes
okay um before we move on what if if if
we look at 2019 and we have that blade
moment yeah i want from all of us what
is our blade moment we've kind of hinted
at that in what that sort of thing at
the end of the panel where kevin feige
is like oh also this huge thing wasn't
this crazy thing that no one was
expecting right like something that we
maybe don't live extra miles morales
oh that would be excellent yeah and by
the way i want to introduce the new
spider-man and it's just you know
whoever walks out oh that would be so
cool it's just a beautiful blonde-haired
white boy
i'm just joking
it's kind of like it's kevin feige
when they did the floor tease and it was
like jj's make it fantastic for it's
like no i'm making comic books with my
boy
with my son
any crazy predictions last minute oh
crazy predictions yeah like the last
like he just said miles morales uh
howard the duck
yeah
is it a continuation from the movie from
the 80s yes yes and leah thompson
continuation howard the duck but also i
just i want to see a little doctor doom
yes
i just want to say i would be thrilled
if dr doom is somehow involved yes yeah
yeah
that'll be a good one
excellent all right
excellent well speaking of good ones we
got a good sponsor today and we want to
thank our friends
at betterhelp this is a real ad by the
way well thank you for the better help
for sponsoring the break room today i
recently decided to seek out some
therapy after some stressful news made
me rethink the way i cope with things
guys i've said before it's often krispy
kreme occasionally it's the jack harlow
meal at kfc now it's better help okay
better help online therapy will assess
your needs
and can match you with your own licensed
therapist in less than 48 hours i've
started and stopped therapy many many
times in my adult life guys it's no
shame in deciding you need a little help
and then you know if things get better
take a break getting back started with
better help is so easy i i promise you i
signed up for this in minutes and it
still felt like they got enough
information about me it wasn't just like
hey we're gonna give you a therapist now
chill out
it was really cool it was really easy
and i've been messaging with my
therapist already it's easy enough for
me to do and ask anyone around here
technology is not my forte i have a
computer that just screams no when i
turn it on oh no ah it's not a crisis
line guys it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online
available to people worldwide you can
log into your account anytime and
message your therapist as i said i've
already been doing that you can schedule
weekly video or phone sessions so you
don't have to be on camera if you don't
want to and getting therapy every week
is as easy as a few clicks on your
laptop or phone i mean it's never been
easier to get some help and not feel so
hopeless so take advantage of it and
this is really good for us if you guys
use our link they have a special offer
for our breakers our roomies it makes us
look good to our sponsors too so get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
break room that's 10 off your first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
slash break room join me in uneffing our
heads everybody yeah speaking of
uneffing our heads
it's time for mandatory fun
oh my god we raised too much money again
someone donated 60 during that better
help
they said get this help another one
another one oh my
lord i kind of i'm kind of enjoying this
we just finished the bowl
the pain the pain is like it's kind of
nice now yeah there's better help
the pain is my new normal
but we do want to we do want to think
better but we do want to add guys these
ads are new our break room ads so when
you use our code you know we get to
stick it in eric vos's face so anyway
time for mandatory fun did we play the
graphic yes
the segment so spicy we played the
graphic twicey hit it again
the segment so caliente we play the
graphics tray hit it again
this segment
so
abhorrently hot that we play the graphic
for
all the thoughts there you go
the segment that makes your tongue feel
so alive we play the graphics five are
you drinking the creamer i don't know
how to drink the camera all right i
brought it as a bit because you i did
bring this a bit but if you want to
drink it you drink it i could try it
with another bubbly i gotta pee my pants
too much lipstick
guys this man's very fun
i've been hearing
wow
that's a difference no by the way you
are always welcome to interrupt me like
that during this show
don't whatever
you want to do that again wow
all right stop the graphic again palette
cleanser
don't put me up
oh my god we only have 20 more minutes
uh all right so i've been hearing
whispers all weekend they're all weak
about some stupid convention in san
diego no one really cares about it i
hear that convention is for losers
unkissables as i call them
i'm so impatient i'm so unhappy
please go to camera three
oh hashtag unkissable army
nft comics
oh i know i can't believe my eyes are
going probably is that on monday
we are already well into a dynamic
comic-con hashtag slash jestfest and
then that will be monday and the episode
we may be doing i'm trying to negotiate
right now with our overlords it may be
an oversized episode it may go to 4 30.
so in honor of uh comic-con i thought we
would you know maybe pay homage to the
whatever comic-con the unkissables uh
put on our feige hats
and make some new rockstar style
comic-con announcements so
uh i'll go first i'll be kevin
uh can you introduce me though i'd like
a holly introduction and welcome to the
stage kevin feige hello everyone
great voice for that
what's up marvel fans we love you all so
much hey new rock stars fans is what i
meant to say we have such an exciting
slate here at nr
i want to announce a really exciting
oh my god my brain is short-circuited i
want to announce a really exciting new
program
launching soon
play the graphic it's nude rock stars
that's right it's our all nude channel
where we will be reviewing
uh all the greatest nudity in movies
okay nude rock stars is coming i'm
talking
what's your face shannon elizabeth from
american pie
it's going in the channel uh
the dude fast bender who pushes his
penis against the window
in shame
that we're gonna be doing that
uh
kevin bacon and the woodsman stop
everybody's gonna anyone you throw dong
you show hongs it's going on the channel
okay
get them out and we are so excited for
the future of new rock stars yeah and
blade's coming
oh man the first naked body is blade
thank you everyone for coming to
comic-con uh sure yeah i'd love to be
introduced welcome marvel producer kevin
feige thank you for having me today
thank you for being here alcohol h
everybody um we have a couple of quick
announcements before we get going uh
you've loved phase one
of new rockstars i want to introduce you
to phase two of new rock stars wow eric
voss
can only make so much content
he's also aging
incredibly quickly yeah like jack like
movie jack movie jack sorry i'm the guy
on stage
yeah yeah
i will say this creamer work though you
guys
okay i still got to be honest the
bubbles i'm going to dunk it up first
we've invented some incredible
technologies here at new rock stars and
i wanted to introduce our next
incredible achievement in engineering
wow
animatronic eric voss wow we have taken
all of the voice recordings of eric voss
thank you you can see him demoed right
here we've taken all the voice
recordings of eric voss and a skin that
is close
and put him into this incredible
animatronic
welcome back to you rock stars today i'm
breaking down gummy bears the cartoon
episode six the bears melt
some cakes to be worked out but we'll
see you next year also blaze must
destroy philip must destroy phil kill
phillip kill up molina kill up
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen you know him from
marvel
you know him from comic-con you know him
from complaining that marvel trailers
give away too much information give it
up for the lord of lightning the saucy
boss kevin
foggy
i have an afro today
so i'm actually gonna take this back off
i'm gonna take this bad boy off for a
second no problem we gave you we're good
we gave you
avengers age of ultron
we've given you eternals
we've given you
everything that you've desired in the
superhero realm and now what we're
giving you here from new rock stars
is
life swap now i know what you're
thinking jessica wait no kevin feige is
not that really close to wife's lock
swipe swap
oh no why swap and it is you always
always asking us where's mt where's eric
boss this time we're switching places
with those bad boys we're sending tommy
to boston to go fight in the blue
dungeon and we're gonna send mt here to
have to deal with all of us all the time
what do you hear about my color theory
there you go it's all about clown makeup
yes yes and then we also already are in
the works for a spin-off show uh it's
called uncharted love where we make
everybody from new rock stars marry one
another
we pull the names out of the hat yeah
and that's how we decide who's marrying
each other wow
coming in 2024
[Laughter]
all right ladies and gentlemen this is
unbelievable
please
welcome to the stage the man with the
plan
the jacks with the axe
the guy with all the answers to the
questions you didn't know you needed
ladies and gentlemen marvel head honcho
kevin
feige
hire me oh okay all right you're hired
all right so i'm so excited sorry my
nose is a little runny i've been eating
some hot chips uh so we've got so much
fun stuff planned uh coming up soon we
we got like lots of fun stuff but i want
to
introduce something to you today i i
know you're looking forward to x-men but
hear me out what about the wyman
why men yes they are all young yeah yeah
they're like they all do the wine
he just confirmed why men oh my god i'm
freaking out don't ask me about the z-ma
no no
we're gonna go eventually through the
entire alphabet but the y men is
confirmed and uh they all have very very
special and useless powers that they
find a use for
wow has anyone been cat hang on i have a
question uh yes uh i wrote a script
that's about an alien
who uh
just digs holes with his fingers and
then sticks his tongue in the hole that
he digs would you read it for me and
then produce it and make it a movie and
make my dreams come true follow-up
question have you cast anyone in the
y-man yet
um so the y-man does have some casting
it's uh it's just going to be
sir patrick stewart as everybody like
dude
eddie murphy situation
he plays the whole family
i'm in guys this has been an
unbelievable mandatory fun i don't even
think we need a poll i'm declaring
everyone the winner today for eating
these chips johnson if you want to run a
poll we will we won't accept the results
stop the steal uh
what's that results are fake
the polls today no do you want to you
can i my eyes are crossed dude i'm not i
can do it here we go here we go what are
you more excited about house of dragon
mortal kombat two very close pull 50
percent these have been razor
dragon i'm more excited about house of
the dragon too um do you think purple
lightsaber would have been fitting for
leia 74 say yes i think the context
helps yeah
context is helpful for me but i think
that would have been super cool yeah um
which role would you have ryan gosling
play in the mcu we had a few options
nova captain canada ghost writer and
other
41 want nova wow we all just want to
know them who's others what is others
powers i want
well
i'll tell you that i have to pee so bad
i'm so sorry
get out of here and drink eight thousand
cups of water can we mute tommy's mom
oh yeah
you're gonna want to hear this
we're just gonna
sit here real quiet for the next 20
minutes while he i can't we just
um
we asked some of you guys on twitter
we're going to get to some super chats
as well during this uh little segment we
asked some of you guys on twitter what
you're most excited about for comic-con
what your wildest predictions are i want
to sort of go through those and kind of
get your guys's take on
on all of these so uh lost jeez says on
twitter secret wars release date 2025.
say one more time i'm so secretive
release date 2025. that's too soon
that's way too soon that's way too soon
baby we're already over the halfway park
to 2023. yeah uh infinity war and
endgame started shooting in like 2001.
also i think we need to think about
what's coming out during those times so
we're not conflicted and uh stranger
things has already been like ready for
2024. i don't think they want to come
out around the same time as like any
other bigger property and there's a lot
of more properties that are already
started filming and they're going to
issue it out in 284 okay so i just think
there's too much for a 2025 i'm sorry
that's just me i'll go 2025 you're
taking it i don't know wait wait what's
what are the simulations here what's
this i'll take that deal no in my
bedding these are no these are just some
things that people have predicted online
i just want to get your opinion i'll
take it okay wild
wild
curious about what if season two this is
from megan livengood curious about what
if season two keep hearing different
reports on when to expect it would be
cool to see a trailer for that i think
we will see a trailer for that i will
say i agree i thought it was going to
get dropped this year
we have some friends that are working on
it
sorry someone in the comments i'm sorry
i said that's going to be a spicy pee
jake hedge with the spices jake you want
to write comedy for me
um yeah what do you think we'll see what
if season two i think it's gonna be
announced at comic-con and then it'll
come out in like 2023. i can see it
coming out you know we've got she-hulk
coming out in august and then we don't
have anything until black panther
wakanda forever in december i could kind
of see it i guess we have
group we have the holiday special we've
got werewolf by night um but no more
series for the rest of the year i can
see it being i think it's sort of in
that hawkeye slot or no no no next i'm
getting a no from jessica i'm getting a
note from jessica i'm back
welcome back how'd it go
oh you're not good a lot of blood oh no
are we talking super chats now we've had
so many characters
dan from the multiverse has a crazy one
a fantastic forecast announcement john
krasinski will direct the rock will
introduce the return of henry cavill as
superman in his black adam movie we
didn't talk about that but there was a
rumor today that henry cavill could come
back as superman
i wouldn't be surprised bring him back
into my life in any way i don't know
that was a lot in that one oh no i'm not
saying that you guys on twitter didn't
announce nice you asked great
questions take our super chatters yeah
easy says i just want jensen echols in
the mcu and a scarlet witch teased soon
at san diego comic con or not is fine
enjoy more chips you satanist thank you
for the money no thank you for that oh
yeah yeah i added some flavor rachel
grande oh i was going to say i would
love to see a scarlet witch tease yeah
scarlet witch i don't think he'll get
another one for a little bit yeah she's
gotta relax for a bit yeah i think she
should go to hell like right like she
should have to escape hell for that'd be
sick you know messing around with the
dark hole and then get back out i'd be
sick if someone like goes uh to hell or
whatever and they see her just hanging
out
and that's what we get of mephisto yes
uh so rachel grande said tomicon should
include cosplay based on the
announcement at comic-con i would love
listen i don't know who's attending
comic-con because you know i'm just in
charge of you know
uh being myself and
and
showing up every day with a positive
attitude but i would be thrilled if
people dressed up for tomicon i
obviously can't legally demand that they
do
but i can make it mandatory
ooh jenny davis says i think one of my
children distracted me at the end of
thor love and thunder could someone
please explain how thor got mjolnir back
and in one piece
uh well we did see in that earlier scene
he just sort of lifted up mjolnir and
was like oh cool it's i still got the i
still i'm still working
so i think he's just uh he'd get it back
in one piece i can't remember that scene
it comes back in one piece itself yeah i
know but like at what what what point
did it it wasn't when they were in front
of eternity
i think she's maybe talking about the
post-credit scene guys he's with love
relationships are difficult it's a lot
like an omelette the eggs crack but if
you love someone hard enough the eggs
will reform as full complete eggs with
no cracks in them again um
i promise you if you love someone tommy
logic throw eggs at them and crack the
eggs
if they love you back the eggs will
leave their body and rejoin your hands
as complete eggs austin long says is it
too far-fetched to think that the mcu
mutants x-men mostly were previously
made aware the direction the world was
heading after the sokovia course and
just went into early hiding that's a fun
take they were like oh this accords
thing is like messed
[Music]
way back when eric has sort of
speculated that it's possible that the
radiation caused by the multiple snaps
oh yeah is what sort of like mutated
people's genes and then if you think
about that maybe it was just like
oh
people born during that time have the x
gene and maybe now they're just coming
of age and are realizing that they're
mutants so maybe that's so like
some sadist asked if they donate the
remainder amount of money to get us over
into another chip thing who will eat the
last chip i think we'll all i will
suffer for it if we get over
if we get another fifty dollars i'll
shove a handful of chips in my mouth
i'll do that i do kinda wanna see that
i'll donate um reed cold says reed
cole's excuse me says my blade moment
would be an avengers five no
confirmation of secret wars just
jonathan majors walking out hey
i think they've gotta announce an
avengers team-up movie soon yes right
yeah i don't know who is an avenger now
well whether it's not well and young
avengers counts right dog shout out to
keith thank you keith nate dog layla or
are you just saying like the adults
i say i say lump them together
cuz i
but i would love to see kate bishop like
firing an arrow at kang that'd be fun
yeah
yeah i put them all together um grinch
fingers says wait what great fingers
i'm super excited for quantum media kang
baby i i think like the kang gang baby
of course yeah and not to our lovely
empty yeah um i want quantum mania so
badly
jeff love this uh the guy who used to
write all the kimmel sketches that i did
with as uh princess leia is the writer
of uh
of uh of quantum media why are we not
being cast in that film yeah you know i
think somewhere along the line jeff gave
up on me
is it because fingers took no i'm just
joking jeff also wears some of your
favorite episodes of rick and morty he's
a very very talented writer and i'd love
to work with him again someday
dj grinch fingers
you're
who's that you really are a hill oh no
you're slimy as a slippery snake your
cactus like a prickly plate mr
always the right side of the table you
never know who's coming for you till you
bubble the spice
99 and a half food pool
better
remember
than
we get 49 tommy will in fact scoop this
bowl of chips and eat it like an animal
there's some things in the super chat
comments that i don't know what they
mean so i'm not going to read them but i
do want to just say thank you to iroc
4031.
thank you to
diezo kid
uh thank you to this is me
oh well what kind of forever set up a
disney plus a koi a series oh yes wait
didn't they talk about it or was it was
it
i saw a lot of commotion about this on
twitter and i'm completely on board most
i'm on board we get a little white wolf
i've heard things but it's been very low
that's why i'm wait i've been i've been
trying to look into it and then i got
distracted by the whole uh 300 apartment
trend
for gotham on twitter but i would love
to know if that is actually confirmed
because i would eat battle
we've got a few more disgusting super
chatters that are trying to kill us john
attends says after seeing christian bale
play gore the god butcher i think he
would play a good joker in the next
batman movie too bad we're getting barry
keogh and you have no sense that how you
say his last name we're also 29 away
29.00
[Applause]
all right to the office bathroom after
all these chips maya or myra you have no
idea we've had to fix this bathroom
seven or eight the office bathroom's
just a hole in the floor now
this is a bad time to say this but i've
only eaten coffee and peanuts today
before
so
oh
[Music]
my digestive tract we're not over yet
sorry guys thank you so much for
watching the break room we are so close
we're not dipping you you guys i'm going
to dive
tune in tomorrow tune in friday do you
guys want to see your handles with your
plugs
we normally sometimes do that yeah you
want a point we have new people
i always eat this chip but okay
[ __ ] yourself go oh it's hard when you
just inhale it a little bit um
i had a spicy chip hello or goodbye
um i'm a tray or angelica tray on most
um platforms as well as uh streaming on
twitch most days so if you want to come
through and hang out we'd be happy to
have you
i know i have to don't follow me
look at my baby girl don't follow me
anywhere um lulu underscore cleveland's
at tommy bechtold he's the christmas i
also have a video coming out soon i'm
doing the note breakdown and it's gonna
be coming out next week and i just want
to thank everybody in the chat for
watching the breakdown for the boys
always talking for me and being nice for
me thank you bye